judge robert satyr a trial judge in
connecticut and author of a new book
called doing justice a trial judge at
work what's the worst part about being a
judge worst part about being a judge the
worst part the worst part i think at the
moment is the crush of criminal cases
which makes much of what a judge does
somewhat irrelevant specifically i mean
that there's such a crowdedness in the
courts in the jails these such an
overcrowded nest that for every person
put into jail prison somebody has to be
let out and as a result sentences that
judges impose or simply not served in
connecticut 1/10 of a sentence is
actually served before a person is let
out because the overcrowded miss of the
court so I'd say I guess the most
frustrating aspect of being a judge is
not having one's own decision in one's
own sentences carried out how long have
you been on the bench 15 years how did
you get there elected appointed how'd it
go
pointed as a consequence of being
involved in politics in the state of
Connecticut why did you write this book
I wrote the book in order to understand
the experience of writing a book no
understanding the experience of being a
judge I had as every judge does heard
case after case after case and and I
just wanted to get a hold of it and put
the experience in some coherent form I
remembered the line of Socrates and
unexamined life is not worth living and
I just decided that I better examine my
own experience and so I wrote the book
to understand what I was doing well
what's your conclusion after writing the
book my conclusion after writing the
book is that what I suspected as I was
going through the experience is that is
that a judge has a vast discretion in
deciding many many cases and who the
judge is makes a big difference judge is
part of his judgment not in all cases of
questions where the law is six the judge
follows the trial judge particularly
follows the law there was a clear
statute trial judge likewise advisable
but there's a vast amount of discretion
in the administration of the law from a
judge's point of view I found that it
made a difference who I was making the
decisions that I made other judges might
not have made the same decision are you
a different kind of judge now than you
were fifteen years ago
I don't think so really maybe I've
changed maybe other lawyers could say of
James I think I had a pretty a pretty
firm handle on what I was about before I
became a judge I'd been a lawyer for a
number of years for 20 25 years I'd been
a legislator and I'd had a lot of
experience in the courts so I came to
the bench with a pretty firm conception
of society in a human nature do you
think it's possible to be named a judge
at too young of an age yes by all means
terrible mistake for a person certainly
a person before 40 becoming a judges I
think a mistake in his life
it's a it's a you should be more
involved in the community of judges very
much out of the community
he can't be involved in so many of the
affairs of society and it's a big shame
to deprive oneself of that experience by
becoming a judge to rule yet we've had
some Supreme Court justices who are
younger than 40 I know that well I
suppose the Supreme Court you take that
becomes your career but I think for the
average person if he had his choice as
to when he would like to become a judge
if he knew he could become a judge at a
certain age I would suspect that most
people would feel they should be close
to 50 before they became it - how old
were you when you became a judge I was
55 what's the most common myth about
being a judge I guess the most common
myth about being a judge is that is that
a judge has only one choice to make you
must follow the law and the law is
inexorable and his job is to just find
out what the law is and
put it that imprint on a case that I
think is most common myth what's the
truth the truth is that a lawyer that a
judge has a lot of choices that again I
say sometimes the law is very fixed but
other times even that precedents differ
and the judge has a right to make a
choice of what present he's going to
follow sometimes the issues or the issue
is right at the edge of precedents and
and a judge can decide which way he
wants to go and in many other kinds of
cases like our Court hears although
several involve criminal cases that a
traditional Superior Court case but in
addition our court hears family cases
hears juvenile cases and housing court
cases and as a consequence there's a
vast amount of discretion we can make in
deciding cases what involves people's
law is very directly in the book doing
justice you've got a chapter devoted to
the general notion of how you decide a
court case and would you talk a little
bit about that in citing some specific
examples yes first of all there's
there's a general conception that as I
guess I said before that lawyer that
judges have to just find out what the
law is and when they find it they apply
it the legal realists say the judges
don't consider themselves with the law
at all but they just simply come to a
conclusion where they want to go and
then find principles to justify their
decision the truth is probably halfway
between there are some cases where the
law as certain as I've said in the law
applies there are other cases that are
in between there are other kinds of
cases like equity cases cases where the
judge simply has to be fair for example
a case in which a judge has to decide
whether to order specific performance of
a contract Pacific performance is an
equitable remedy a judge has a right to
just decide what is the fairest thing to
do under the circumstances and in those
kinds of cases the judges values very
much come into play
a judges experiences come into play his
life's experiences
in that in a case involving a specific
performance question a black person is
seeking to buy a home from a white
couple which had decided at one moment
to sell the house and then had
reconciled decided to continue to live
together and decided not to sell the
house and so the black person sued for
specific performance and the white
couple said listen we made a mistake
give them whatever damages they suffered
but don't kick us out of our own home
which we've lived in for a number of
years and the question came what is the
fair thing to do my own life's
experiences had been that I had once in
that very town that was involved in this
case it represented a black person who
had sought to buy a house of the town
and eventually he felt the only way he
could buy it was to have somebody else
act for him and he didn't even appear at
the closing so nobody knew that he was a
black person going out I appeared and I
handed him the deed he was delighted to
the other house well that experience
there was a life experience it very much
affected my decision in the case of the
black couple buying this house in the
case before me I decided that it was
that it was being much harder for that
couple to ever buy a house in that town
they had a contract and I felt the
fairest thing was that they should get
the house and so I granted the specific
performance but the decision was based
upon my own life's experience and you
could have easily gone the other way I
could have easily gone the other way and
another judge might have gone the other
way
was there a epilogue to that story there
was there was an appeal to the appellate
court and the court affirmed them you
are a trial court judge is that means
there so is somebody looking over your
shoulder Oh what is your thinking when
you're deciding knowing that there's a
state Supreme Court that could overturn
your decision well a judge trial judges
are always aware of that and it requires
that they apply the law they can't be
freewheeling they have to apply the law
when the law is is positive and clear
and even when it's not clear you seek to
and to
to guess as to what the Supreme Court
will do on the situation no judge wants
to be reversed on the other hand you
can't be so constricted with concern
about reversal that you don't try to
reach the right result in the given case
and hope that the Supreme Court will see
it the same way as you would and so
you're aware of it you're upset by the
fact that sometimes sure reverse but
that's the lot of a childhood
don't take this question wrong but it
comes from your book which I read last
night do judges have to be pompous no
they don't have to be if it's part of
the judicial malady to be inclined
toward pomposity what leads judges to
pomposity fact that everybody is
obeisance to them the fact that
everybody calls them judge or your honor
on and off the court even on the tennis
court the fact you start to think you're
pretty important and some people can't
resist you've got an interesting portion
of the book that's devoted to the
effects of speaking on the record all
the time
well that gives rise to the judicial
malady of ponderous Ness judge
everything a judge says in court is on
the record it's in the transcript and
anybody who's ever seen a transcript of
what he says has got to be humble it's
all the fractured syntax all the split
infinitives all the incoherences even
this very tape if who were printed would
be embarrassing probably in a way maybe
while I'm not talking to imposing on you
so when a judge realizes that everything
he says is going to be on the record he
speaks more slowly and he sounds
ponderous do you see much poor advocacy
in front of you some yeah
how do you as a judge respond when you
see an obviously inadequate presentation
either a defense or a prosecution well
that's a hard thing to do something
about first I mean the judges is
presiding over what is called the
adversary system where the truth is
supposed to be revealed by both sides
putting on their Kay
without the judge intervening when a
judge does intervene on the side of an
incompetent lawyer is waiting the scales
against the other side because the jury
is listening and if a judge intervenes
and seems to be implying he's in favor
of another side it's unfair to to the
ones the side against whom you speaking
so it has to be done carefully on the
other hand sometimes it has to be done I
mean you just just justice cries out for
the question being asked that the lawyer
has not asked that you know should be
asked and you anticipate will give the
answer that will make a difference in
the outcome of the case
and judges do it I do it I do it
carefully but I do it what kind of law
did you practice before assuming the
bench well I practice primarily labor
law and trial law and I did a lot of
administrative law before the state
agencies how did your professional life
change moving from practicing lawyer to
donning the robe well it changed a lot
really I mean I had been a remember I
had been the senior partner in my law
firm I had partners I had secretaries
and associates and I had a convivial
officer thought I did and I loved we had
a lot of fun I enjoyed my clients and
enjoy the freedom of going doing
whatever I wanted to do he's off to
Fenway Park whenever I had an urge to or
down the Forest Hills as he attends me
as a judge the first and most important
shock I had really was was the
loneliness of a job sent to a town for a
fairly far from where I lived I didn't
know anybody in town
there was nobody to have lunch to with
at lunch by myself which was a very
strange experience
I left the courtroom at the end of the
day there was nobody to say goodnight to
I went home to my my home and worked on
my opinions and lonely isolation and
that was a that was a shock to me
it took a long time to get used to them
you take a pay cut sure dude what do you
think of that well I did it I mean at
that point in my life I was anxious and
ready to be a judge and the pay didn't
make that much difference but I sure did
take a picture but it makes a difference
to some judges oh it makes a difference
to the young my children at that point
we're all in college but almost out of
God but boy these young younger people
in their 40s who have children in
college if it's a pity is a terrible
strain what should we do about judicial
pain
I think nobody should should be denied
the opportunity to serve on the bench
because of pay and I think the page
should be commensurate with the
responsibility I think the federal
judges are if they have their pay raise
yet I never know where they are on that
a little we've had a little and state
courts are always behind the federal
court
I think the pay should be commensurate
with with the job I mean it's a it's
frankly it has been the case that that
the large law firms in York hire young
first-year hire people just out of law
school and pay them more than many
judges get in this country I mean a
$65,000 a year salary paid to a law
school graduate is not the amount that
many judges get in the United States in
your book you make several receptive
suggestions for court reform such as
personal injury Awards let's talk about
some of those suggestions well I do have
one suggestion about that I think that
the real difficulty that I have with
with the civil jury system we're not
talking about personal juries making
giving verdicts and personal injury case
is the erratic quality of those
decisions the same injury gives rise to
a to a verdict of $20,000 or $40,000 or
20,000 there is no rationalization of
jury verdicts on injuries and lawyers
know this it results quite frankly in Y
cases are settled because defendants
just don't want to take a chance with
juries but the the basis for the jury
erratic
decision-making on verdicts is that they
really a they don't have any experience
be they don't get any help from the
judge the judge tells the jury in a
personal injury case when it comes to
damages you award fair just and
reasonable compensation he can say that
over 20 times but isn't going to tell a
jury him and thirdly and most important
jurors don't know what the parties
really want in the case the result is
their their verdicts are as erratic as
lottery I think that a personal injury
case should be tried first by a
determination of the liability is the
doctor negligent in the treatment of his
patient as the as the defendant been
negligent in the operation of the the
automobile etc when the jury decides the
question of liability for the plaintiff
or the person bringing the action the
evidence should be put upon the upon the
damages what has the plaintiff suffered
what's the nature of the injury what's
the consequence of the injury on the on
the plaintiffs life etcetera the end of
all the evidence the judge should call
with two lawyers into his chambers and
say to the plaintiff all right what do
you want what number do you want to
submit to the jury
you want to submit to the jury as what
you think the evidence resilient reveals
to be fair fair damages and he may say
$100,000 and the defend then the judge
should ask the defendant what he thinks
defendant may say well I think the
evidence is not going to give any more
than 50,000 and then the judge can say
should say to the lawyers all right you
want to change either of your numbers in
light of the others number because the
judges the juries only decide one number
or do not in between so if you think mr.
plaintiffs that you're too high they're
going to choose the defendants alone if
the defendant is too low you're going to
choose the plaintiffs number so
eventually maybe they'll come a little
closer to the middle and then they
should argue to the jury the plaintiff
saying having reduced his number I think
mr. mrs. members of the jury you should
pay my client eighty thousand dollars
and this is the reason pointing to a
specific number and the plaintiff the
defendant should say the case having
already liability having been
established should pay sixty thousand
and they should argue to the jury should
choose one of the other the consequence
of that is is that whatever verdict the
jury comes back with it's going to be a
rational number that both parties have
essentially established as what they
think is the fair value of the case and
you won't get the hundred fifty thousand
dollar case or the million dollar
verdict that nobody expected you also
have some suggestions about jury
instructions jury instructions isn't it
first of all it's an art the judge you
who gives an accurate statement of the
law written read from previous court
opinions may be accurate from the point
of view of the appellate court but may
not be communicating much to the to the
to the jury so that a jury in strike
court instruction on the law to the jury
my judgment should be clear should be
accurate but it's also be clear and as
much legend as close to layman's
language as it can be retaining its
accuracy but I also think that
instructions during judges instructions
to the jury
should be in writing they're not now
they're not now they're not in most
states
I don't be there in the federal courts
either the result is the jury hears a
judge expound on what the law is that
there that the jury itself is to apply
to the facts and reach the decision and
they have hard either a understanding or
be remembering it when they're in the
jury having it in writing would enable
them to ponder over it and and I think
apply it better why is it a suggestion
for reform that the jury should be
allowed to ask questions it sounds like
an obvious suggestion it's not allowed
in virtually any state although it's
it's getting to be allowed
there's a recent recent experiment made
by the American Judicature SIA T to
allow juror to permitted to have judge
judges permit jury to ask question and I
participated in and I've done it even
before then it's a wonderful thing I
don't know why the lawyers opposed the
lawyers think that they're the problem
they're trying of the case is being
invaded
but how wrong they are if a if a juror
has a question that he wants to ask of a
witness because as the witness hasn't
made something clear why isn't the
lawyer delighted with that so he can
have that matter cleared up or bringing
up their evidence to to answer the
question in the in the jury's mind well
I let the jury sit there as fixes but at
any idea what goes on in their mind and
what doubts have been created by the
case I'm very much in favor of juries
being allowed to ask questions what
about the effort especially on the
federal level for sentencing guidelines
does that remove too much of your
discretion or don't you care oh I care a
lot that's first of all discretion in
sentencing is is is let me put a stage
in other words the variety of sentencing
based on the on the on the individual
judge is very great it's dramatic we in
a lot of states in Connecticut for
example we have sentencing seminars
where the judges will get on one piece
of paper all the facts about a given
case and nature of the crime the facts
about the the defendants background it's
and then they're asked to give an
opinion in Connecticut we in these
sentencing seminars the the suggested
sentences vary all over the law from
probation to ten years on any given
drawing so that variety of sentencing
disparity in sentencing is a significant
fact in the administration of the
criminal justice system the federal
courts have adopted strict guidelines
where the judge where the judge
sentencing judges is allowed is required
to give a certain sentence based upon
certain standards and can vary it only
by a relatively small amount the judge
some of the federal judges seem restive
under that we don't have that in
Connecticut so I can't really tell how
it works
my concern only is is that while I
believe there should be uniformity of
sentences because it's a quality of
justice that sentence should not be
dependent on before whom a defendant
happens to come at the same time I don't
think any dispute I don't think all
discretion should be taken from judge
because there are individual
circumstances that require individual
judgment child custody cases you have
any thoughts about those none of those
are very very hard dealing with with a
person's law with people's lives and
Court listens with a lot of anguish to
the testimony on both sides and tries to
make the right decision I had a case
just tell you briefly about it in which
a woman had a child before she was
married and a mother was so upset that
you wouldn't let the woman that would
let the mother come home so the charr
the mother married the father of the
child very unhappy marriage and the
woman came out of the marriage and again
wanted to take the child home with her
and her mother wouldn't allow her so she
gave up custody to the father and her
husband five years later her life
changed and she had remarried and now
was living in a very nice home in a
suburb of Hartford and wanted the child
back
and the fight and the meaning on the
father had himself been raising the
child remarried was raising the child
the child was a very happy little boy a
very hard decision on that question in
the end I decided to let the child stay
with the father but when I left the
courtroom I was told by the sheriff that
the two the couple embraced and they had
sort of accepted my decision and I felt
good about do you sometimes have trouble
sleeping at night over some of the
decisions you have to make before making
for making a decision I agonize over
think about it all the time when I have
a tough case think about in the car
driving to the courthouse I think about
it when I'm shaving I think about it
when I'm having dinner with my wife and
I think about it all the time eventually
I come to a decision a decision when I
come to always want not only think right
not only to be rational based on
rational reasons but also to feel right
to feel it as it hits right within it
and then when I decided it's over with I
never really never well one case I
rethought there was one case that was a
troublesome case a man had been I was
charged with unlawful restraint and
robbery of a woman and the woman had not
been able to identify him in a police
lineup or in police photos but in the
courtroom she readily identified the
defendant who was sitting beside his
lawyer as her assailant courtroom
identifications are notoriously
unreliable the defendant in his defense
said that he was at a he was at a family
party and five members of his family
testified that he had been there the
jury after a very swift deliberation
came back with a conviction they found
the man guilty I didn't think he really
was guilty but and I really believed him
he sounded truthful to me on the stand
and his five members of his family
sounded Jerusalem but the jury had found
him guilty
I had the sentence and I you have no
discretion to overturn a jury verdict
not on a factual question jury had a
right to believe the woman who
identified and I did not have any right
to overturn that so I had a sentence a
sentence a man that I didn't think was
guilty I got the pre-sentence report and
it showed he had committed a number of
other crimes one of which had been
exactly like that for she had previously
been convicted so now I had a man with a
record substantial record of violence
whom I had the sentence and whom I did
not believe was guilty of the crime but
it was the judgment of the jury not mine
and so I sentenced them but that has
always been a troublesome case what
advice did you receive when you rose to
the bench I got one piece of advice old
wise judge told me always put your Road
never put your robe on over your suit
coat and always go to the bathroom
before going on a bench and that was the
sum total of advice I'd cut if you were
advising a brand-new judge let's say a
45 year old man or woman what advice
would you give
I would say to him read my bub
yes read my book I would say to him
have courage have confidence in your own
in your own internal feelings your own
gut feelings try to do justice struggle
to find the right way to solve a problem
which the law seems to be against you if
you can find a a valid way to do it then
do it don't break the law don't deviate
from the law but use the law to achieve
justice who do you hope and expect will
read this book I hope lawyers will read
it I hope judges will read it because I
had a colleague tell me the most
wonderful thing about that book he said
after I read your book I didn't feel so
lonely again I realized that what you
were trying to do was what I've been
trying to do and I hope the lay public
will read it in order to understand what
our system works what tone does the book
take what style well I hope it takes the
style of trying to make it clear I hope
it's its style is one of clarity that's
what I struggled to achieve is it your
first book yes is it your last hope not
what do you think of when you think
about the next book well I've written
the book about my careers as a lawyer in
the legislature and I'm going to try to
to it to make that into a book using the
style of this book using the examples
the way I did in this book that make it
more interesting well thank you judge
Robert SATA I appreciate your time yes
sir